how do you become british had you ever
done an english accent before what do
you do they teach you to place your
tongue in a different place what is it a
lot of it like you have to have an ear
some people can hear stuff some people
can't um
they make it a very physical thing and
they describe what your tongue does how
how um
open your mouth has to be like when i
speak i barely open my mouth and like
everything is all like at the back of my
throat i'm from l.a that's how i talk
whatever when she speaks it's open i
mean just
i have to literally like i look like a
completely different person in trying to
make that sound
um so yeah you just went into it now do
you have to start walking around like
five six hours a day with your mouth
open like kind of getting it i felt like
the way to really do her justice was to
be so present and spontaneous because
like this woman to me in in everything
that i've seen of her is so like live
wire
she feels
a little bit spooky like she walks into
a room and you just don't know what's
gonna happen it feels precarious and
like [ __ ] wild
the script was written
so precisely and perfectly i didn't
ad-lib anything i learned my lines
exactly i worked on the accent with my
coach i just sort of relied on him to
tell me if i was you know
doing something totally wrong but it was
there like uh six months to work on it
and then
yeah i was just sort of
living in it why so if you had that
confidence how come when you go to the
set you get so [ __ ] tight
that your jaw starts to lock up
and uh i read about this and this is a
this is a definite psychological thing
oh yeah i think i wasn't considering the
stress because i was pushing it away
i always i used to use anxiety as like
motivation or i used to be like oh yeah
i need to like torture myself on this
movie and make it really real and
now i function
so much more purely and honestly if i'm
feeling safe and so i i think i was like
designing this world in which i wasn't
afraid
but my body knew better
and uh
yes
two weeks before the movie i literally
couldn't open my mouth i had such
horrible tmj and i was like using like
hot compresses and having like i was
just like rubbing my jaw all day and the
day that we started shooting it just
opened up i wasn't even fixated on my
jaw i was just sort of like so swept up
in the experience i just sort of knew it
was gonna work out it was like at some
point my mouth will open it has to it
has to and if not they'll [ __ ] push a
week and we'll figure it out
you